[Musique]
à mi chemin entre le musée du sucre et
celui du sel à saint leu la savane du
grand stella abritera dans quelques
années ils forêt peuplée d'espèces
indigènes et endémiques de l'art in un
gros projet un grand projet avec
l'ensemble des partenaires la région le
départ prend le décès mais aussi
l'ensemble des associations l'éducation
nationale donc on va faire tout le monde
et chacun son histoire dans cette zone
là pour tous les saint leusiens sont
les 100 premiers plans qui couvriront
les 13 hectares du futur espace végétal
forestiers ont été plantés par les
principaux partenaires du projet le
plaque commémorative à l'occasion du 21
mars journée internationale des forêts a
également été inaugurée il ya une partie
réservée aux arbres endémiques une
partie réservée à l'agriculture pas des
jardins partagés ai dit essaie de faire
en sorte qu'il y ait coulé vers bon
écologique ici à saint leu entre l'
usine de sela le musée de stella et le
faisait tous amis donc ce sont quoi de
60 des cas
vous y pensez à bien à planter des
arbres d'epinal où il ya des enfants est
pour partie liée avec sur un projet en
deux
on a pensé également petits agriculteurs
on a pensé à 30 mille mètres carrés où
il va y avoir aussi
de l'agriculture qui sera mise en route
on a pensé aux habitants qui vivent tout
autour et afin aussi d'avoir ce que l'on
appelle un jardin partagé
une matinée menée par l'équipe du
département en charge du plan un million
d'arbres du conservatoire botanique
national de mascarin avec la
collaboration des agents de
l'association piton saint-leu lève la
tête en charge de l'entretien du site
aujourd'hui on a compté 103 avec nos
différents exécutifs régions
départements et communes les pieds de
bois de la forêt semi sèche avec vous le
voyez une densité relativement élevé
donc mais sur deux plans par mètre carré
c'est une méthode inspirée de la méthode
japonaise dite de monsieur miyagi qui va
favoriser la dynamique de croissance
entre
voir que notre micro forêt urbaine puis
s'être résigné autonome d'ici trois ou
quatre années d'ici cinq ans 90 planté
pour recréer une forêt semi sèche
[Musique]